(intense music)
(garage door opening)
- [Narrator] Today, the attempt will be
to set the fastest speed
ever accomplished in an
aircraft that originally
was made in World War II.
(zipping)
- [Steve] It's a good
question, "Why would you
wanna do something like this?"
And, honestly, there's
no good explanation.
There's no money involved doing it.
I'm sure none of you have
ever heard about this record.
This is 1940's technology.
The engine is commonly breaking.
(engine roaring)
Today, we're squeezing
every last bit of it.
You're traveling at 800 feet per second,
which is faster than a 45 caliber bullet
out of the muzzle.
(plane zooming by)
You have an engine that is screaming loud
in front of you.
The cockpit's 140 degrees inside.
There's no computers.
No digital touch screens.
(static)
You talk to the engine,
console it, caress it.
- Alright, last chance.
Come on, baby.
- Come on, hold together.
You can hold together.
(plane zooming by)
To break this record,
you have to be perfect.